[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis absolument ravi
de vous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
émission si vous avez envie de lecture
70 très très bien n'est ce pas leur
hangar un bon jour avec ce froid
bah oui je suis fait alors je rappelle
que vous êtes libraire à la librairie le
pavé du canal tout à fait inconnu tout
comme stéphanie férial bonjour on est
ravi de vous retrouver merci moi aussi
et puis nous avons la chance d'avoir sur
ce plateau jean charles lajoie ni
bonjour vous êtes éditeur absolument
contre entre autres monsieur mais
surtout est quasiment exclusivement
éditeur chez moi tous alors une
sélection riche aujourd'hui oui sur
leurs choses 2010 16 que la rentrée
d'hiver oui alors vous voulez commencer
leur rampe et être d'accord françois
roux on comparera corneau on part par
pardon parce par les dimanches et
m'accorde pas en angleterre alors c'est
stéphane et moi qui les a vus
effectivement swift est un auteur
anglais donc le dimanche des mers fait
référence en fait à cette demo cette
journée qui était accordée en fait aux
domestiques par les aristocrates en
général effectivement ces personnes
allaient voir leur mère ont donc à la
famille ce n'était pas tout à fait
appeler comme ça s'appelait
effectivement le dimanche des mers donc
on peut effectivement le traduire par la
fête des mères
et on va suivre donc jane qui a on né en
1924 etienne
elle est orpheline dont elle n'a pas de
famille à aller voir et elle va voir son
amant et son amant est le fils de
l'aristocrate voisin qui devrait se
marier d'ici une quinzaine de jours et
qui profitent de cette matinée pour
passer donc ce moment avec avec jen est
en fait cette journée va être capital
dans la vie de jane alors c'est plus par
petits bouts comme ça dans le roman on
va avoir des informations on va
évidemment c'est une vieille dame de 90
ans qui va nous raconter qui elle était
et ce qu'elle a fait et ce qui est
seulement génial c'est ça c'est que par
petites par petits coups de
théâtre le théâtre d'un nom on apprend
qui est jeune et qu'est ce qui s'est
vraiment passé dans cette journée-là qui
a fait que sa vie a totalement mais
totalement basculé et puis on est dans
une période
d'après première guerre voilà les hommes
les fils ne seront pas là en cette halte
à faire tout à fait malgré le fait qu'il
soit quand même très présent par photo
par eau par mémoire tout simplement
mais effectivement en 1924 qui étaient
aussi des années finalement après guerre
pour être qu'ils vont être complètement
charnière germain pour ces 2 2 enfin
société entre guillemets c'est la
frontière va plus du tout être aussi
importante entre l'aristocratie et le
nom de service entre guillemets enfin
c'est la domesticité et ça l'auteur
effectivement le monde très très bien et
puis il ya une autre partie moi qui m'a
énormément plu c'est que c'est un livre
moments lumineux 20 commencé d'une
écriture absolument enfin libre de toute
beauté très sensuelle aussi on le voit
d'ailleurs à la couverture il ya quelque
chose de fait qu'on appelle la cif mais
voilà on avance petit à petit dans ce
dans son histoire à elle et c'est
absolument magnifique
je trouve ce disque très gras si je veux
que cette femme se promène nu de dire
oui effectivement me fait déjà le fait
qu'elle passe cette matinée avec ce
jeune homme il ya déjà beaucoup de
choses qui sont dites là effectivement
lui s'en va la maison est effectivement
vide parce que tout le monde est parti
et elle va comme ça non pas erré mais
passer de pièce en pièce a pas besoin de
s'habiller on est le 30 mars et fait
très très chaud
il a une très belle lumière d'ailleurs
qui est décrite dans le roman et elle
passe comme ça tout nu de pièce en pièce
et c'est finalement nous lecteurs on
comprend qu'elle s'approprie finalement
quelque chose elle n'a pas se promener
tout nu dans une maison qui n'est pas à
elle en plus de ce type de manoir
anglais tel qu'on peut le post imaginé
et ses précurseurs justement de ce qui
va lui arriver
pas trop loin mais il ya vraiment pas
dans ne te donne ta faim moi j'ai pas du
tout retrait l'ambiance downton abbey ça
a été effectivement quatrième de couv je
sais plus quel journaliste
a new yorker je sais qu'il ait appris
nation c'est juste en fait parce que
voilà c'est cette époque là c'est voilà
en 1924 c'est l'histoire d'une jeune
domestique fait une passe du jeune c'est
une belle demeure qui a toutes ont
effectivement en images on peut avoir ça
on peut avoir sa montée dakar moi je
n'ai pas vu dans l'écriture j'ai plus
pensé un ian mcewan c'est tout à fait le
même style vraiment donc voilà et c'est
vraiment un lit de toute beauté très
bien merci beaucoup c'est moi alors type
enchaîné avec le livre mazarine pingeot
qui était lui c'est mon cas moi j'ai
vraiment beaucoup apprécié ce livre là
qui est sur l'histoire de la dictature
argentine
enfin en principalement cette histoire
d'amour en fait éphémère qui va avoir
lieu entre une étudiante française
ça se passe à paris on est tout à fait
en 1981 et ça se passe à paris donc à
une rencontre on en compte très furtive
entre une étudiante et un déporté exilés
réfugiés argentin et ça va être éphémère
très intense
il va disparaître et elle va donc
essayer de comprendre un peu qui était
cet homme pourquoi il espère qu'elle est
qu'est ce qui l'a poussé à quitter son
pays et quitter toute sa famille et en
même temps elle va découvrir son
histoire à elle aussi sur sa propre
famille et finalement le fils va
l'emmener aussi sur sa propre famille
avec la gare de l'algérie donc il ya ces
deux
deux histoires là parallèle qui vont se
confronter et qui vont nous emmener tout
au long du récit sur une feinte sur une
fin mais cette découverte et ce
cheminement très politique de qu'est ce
qui a pu amener des gens à quitter
totalement leur pays de tout rompre et
de vraiment quitter du jour au lendemain
toutes les attaches et d'essayer de
trouver d'autres attaches sur d'autres
pays
voilà toutes ces complications qui
peuvent arriver comme on peut avoir
actuellement avec les réfugiés c'est
vraiment un très très beau roman un très
bon mais il n'y a pas une histoire de
prénom donc ici alors officiel s'appelle
je sais bien que oui oui elle s'appelle
joseph avec un dos quand on va
comprendre pourquoi on affine féminisé
en fait ce joseph son frère dont il ya
aussi ce 70e congrès plein de choses non
dit et qu'on découvre tout au fil du
livre car sur voilà après faut quand
même juste précédé puisque nous on le
sait mais peut-être tout le monde ne le
sait pas c'est quand même la fille de
mitterrand
oui donc non mais évidemment ça
paraissait une évidence
c'est peut-être ça c'est pas rien mais
même par rapport à l'histoire du sud
oui c'est vrai même d'identité et cette
femme qui viendraient sous le poids du
passé des autres et de l'histoire face
cachée de l'histoire
votre découvrir est-ce qu'on enchaîne
louis qui veut parler de tout ce dont on
rêvait de françois c'est encore voilà
alors qui est l'auteur de bonheur
national brut qui était un roman fleuve
sur les années 80 donc il prend toujours
enfin il essaye un peu de prendre
l'atmosphère de l'instant donc là sur
son premier roman c'était les années 80
la selle les années ce 2015 une
chronique des lettres et patrick roy une
vraie chronique de notre époque sur le
chômage
les manifestations des marais mariage
pour tous les cas de charlie hebdo fait
tout ce qu'il a confié avoir très très
contemporain donc cette histoire de
d'une femme qui tombe amoureuse d'une
personne qui finalement va vivre avec
son frère et donc on va voir cette lente
chute de ce trio là infernale et mais
aussi la rédemption donc voilà on
accompagne la chute de ce ce couple
finalement qui s'est formée qui
n'auraient pas dû et voilà sept vit
aussi avec le satellite du frère qui va
venir s'intégrer dans ce couple là qui
va venir tout exploser et comment
comment ils vont s'en sortir
la réception de cette vie dont on rêve
et qu'on a pas finalement pas eu à
autoriser l'entrée pas de procuration
aussi enfin la main sur ces choses là et
donc c'est vraiment c'est l'atmosphère
de notre époque c'est vraiment ce que
nous aussi on a pu vivre sur ces
événements là et voilà c'est vraiment on
nier quoi on est vraiment temps le geste
commencé moi je n'avais jamais lu le
précédent que j'avais beaucoup beaucoup
aimé le bonheur national brut
ouais effectivement on est vraiment
plongés dans dans la france
d'aujourd'hui alors bonheur national
brut on allait des années 80 aux années
2000 c'était l'élection de mitterrand à
l'élection de françois hollande on qu'on
suivait vraiment quatre copains sur sur
ces périodes là et c'est vrai qu'on
était vraiment j'étais replonger dans
ces fin des années 90
enfin voila c'était très très bien et là
moi de ce que j'ai vu pour l'instant
c'est effectivement ça démarre très bien
y laisser un auteur qui est agréable à
lire il est facile à lire on est bien
dedans on
et puis là des personnages qui sont
vraiment très attachant d'accord c'est
du terra turquie est très sympa et c'est
un auteur que vous connaissez aussi dans
saab
oui mais je touche j'ai pas lu celui là
bien évidemment mais c'est tout à fait
intéressant je me gêne j'aime bien cet
aspect chronique qui a dans ce sens nous
dit ouvrages dont que ces critiques
aussi faim il ya toujours un message
sous jacent au récit c'est une vraie
critique aussi de la société quoi
d'accord vraiment donc le point avec
l'auteur ce serait quoi par exemple
tout est foutu et se remettent de pas
mal d'événements finalement on n'a rien
finalement s'en remettre et vous ne
regardiez les informe de résilience avec
beaucoup de travail et de cheminement
mais l'élan de l'espoir c'était
effectivement ils tombaient entre
guillemets ou c'était parfois
effectivement difficile douloureux ou
les illusions qu'on avait à 20 ans aux
voix là et qu'on a plus en 40 ans comme
vous disiez tout à l'heure le chemin est
différent mais finalement il
il était optimiste voilà on est pas
foutu non travers ses nouvelles allez on
passe au coup de coeur poche
l'art de la joie ça vaut quand même
ladjia 3 effectivement livre poche là
qui viennent de paraître qui me tiennent
particulièrement à coeur donc l'art de
la joie qu'on cite effectivement en
premier sapienza est une auteure
sicilienne yards à sanaa
voilà à saint piat nous inquiète un
livre un peu qu'une grosse
c'est un groupe jeune en poche voilà et
c'est l'histoire en fait d'une femme
modesta qui né le 1er janvier 1900 et
qu'on va suivre sur cinquante soixante
dix ans à peu près et c'est passionnant
parce que c'est une fille ni femme
passionnée vain une héroïne absolument
passionné et que l'on suit effectivement
avec en toile de fond l'histoire de
l'italie dont la sicile histoire aussi
de l'europe surtout du bassin
méditerranéen et qui se ferme aussi
c'est une reine qui me plaît c'est aussi
une héroïne qui est qui et enfin
soumises
voilà qui sort toujours une situation
dramatique et qui a fait chier si j'ai
bien compris mais une femme d'avoir wii
et qui a tant fait pour la pour la
définir ce serait le mot liberté tout
simplement d'accord là et effectivement
c'est un livre alors effectivement ça
c'est dans ce jeu le reconnaît on à ira
d'ailleurs de s'arrêter un polar par
exemple au milieu voilà d'aquin pleut
mmm essais mais c'est un livre qui qui
qui reste elle a été découvert par une
force voilà tout à fait un peu tombé
dans l'oubli en italie vol 1 française
on enchaîne avec alors christophe
boltanski la voile a parlé un peu en
question
le neveu le neuf le neveu ou pas
intervenu c'est vrai que c'est une
famille vraiment un vêtement
particulière de voltaire luc boltanski
le sociologue donc le artistes
plasticiens et lui christophe qui est
dans la journée a dit un jour quand même
tourner oui sept heures oui tout à fait
ce voilà tout à fait effectivement ça se
retrouve beaucoup l'aï sinon le lard
donc la cage fait référence en fait à
l'appartement rue de grenelle où la
famille vit encore d'ailleurs je crois
et où ils vivent tous vraiment non
toujours tous vécu ensemble
la cache à leur faux pas le dévoiler
parce que c'est quelque chose de
particulier
quand même en s'embrassant voilà ce qui
va se faire c'est comme dans un seconde
guerre mondiale et c'est parce que de là
où ils devront faire face aux lilas
c'est pas là donc c'est un hommage un
peu d'artifices à ses grands parents
oui mais a aussi à sa famille et là
aussi on trouve le mot liberté c'est une
famille de deux assez dingue assez folle
monde aimerait on aimerait découvrir
tout le monde l'année croisée en train
d'une liberté effectivement folle aussi
et qui font justement des gens purdy
n'aggrave voilà on est obligé
d'enchaîner rapidement ya pas de ces
zones et non sur petit piment oui alors
peut-être non
on a essayé alors atteignant quelques
riches supplément c'est un petit bijou
c'est un petit bijou alain mabanckou on
s'en lasse jamais voilà qui se passe au
congo et petits piments c'est un mélange
de gavroche et de oliver twist ça ça
dans le kobo dangereux l'un est un
orphelin d'accueil on suit en même temps
voilà aussi l'histoire du congo et c'est
pimenté comme peut l'être nucléaire et
c'est un petit bijou c'est la lire et
puis la couverture je trouve que voilà
c'est une sortie poche et je trouve
qu'il a bien fait les choses
ah oui bah l'effort c'est un super c'est
vrai merci beaucoup d'événements jean
charles haas qui a des petites
nouveautés du côté de chez vous du côté
de chez moi il ya retour amer de fabrice
pichon qui sort la semaine prochaine
enfin en tout cas c'est sa maman sous
peu c'est deuxième polar de fabrice
pichon consorts chez nous mais c'est son
septième livre une histoire passionnante
personnages récurrents
une commissaire de police une marianne
braqué un voyage de concarneau à
besançon alors j'en remercie beaucoup et
à très bientôt pour une nouvelle
émission
[Musique]